parce que nous sommes les héritiers
d'une longue histoire écrite au fil de
nos 78 congrès cette histoire c'est
celle du courage
nous sommes le maillon d'une grande
chaîne qui remonte à la révolution
française
une scène que nous voulons prolonger qui
nous relie à des milliers à 10 millions
de femmes et d'hommes illustres ou
anonymes qui se sont battus avant nous
dans des conditions bien plus difficile
que les autres par leur courage et nous
ont enseigné que si nos ennemis ou des
fonds parfois nous traversons des crises
profondes
rien rien ne peut nous avoir
définitivement les grandes idées ne
meurent jamais alors
alors ayons confiance en nous soyons
fiers
non pas de lui même n'aurait aucun sens
mais soyons fiers de notre histoire et
le sait que nous sommes chers camarades
sa camarade
chaque canal dans quelques minutes vous
allez reprendre le chemin de vos
communes et moi je rentrerai à
savigny-le-temple demain dans les jours
qui suivront dans la rue la boulangerie
ou au café je serai interpellé alors
monsieur le député s'est passé commande
à vihiers sait comment ce congrès eh
bien je leur dirai que ce congrès fut
celui la fraternité retrouvée et nous
avons réussi à nous parler sans nous
déchirer
je leur dirai que nous allons travailler
tous ensemble et qu'ils peuvent déjà
nous rejoindre nous avons besoin d'eux
de leurs idées j'étais avec eux que nous
voulons reconstruire la gauche mais vous
chers camarades vous qui comme moi
avaient participé à ce congrès
j'aimerais que vous remportiez cette
conviction que ce 8 avril que ce
dimanche 8 avril fut le premier jour de
notre renaissance
if they alisme
vive la gauche vive la république et
vive la france
[Applaudissements]